[Musik]
das jahr 1832 ein fremder und hofft auf
immense im schlepptau eine unheimliche
kirche der revolverheld aus dem korb des
gleichnamigen spaghetti-western von 1966
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in dieser graphic novel reist er jakob
mandy ist ein jüdischer dies beratung
er findet unterschlupf auf dem hof der
honey einer tüchtigen unabhängigen bauer
sitzen
doch sie wird vom brutalen
großgrundbesitzer orly der die nach
seinen vorstellungen zu koppeln
er ist der dorfkönig sorgt mit seinen
schläger dafür dass alle nach seiner
pfeife tanzen müssen
gewalt ist seine sprache
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein szenario wien franz schnyders
heimatfilm käserei in der vils leute
nach dem roman von ilija scott der
schweizer heimat ich das spielt hier
sogar persönlich mit unter seinem
richtigen namen albert pcs als klebriger
wie graf von lüttich liegt er um die
gunst der attraktiven witwe pult doch
die bedrängte bäuerin fühlt sich zur
mysteriösen fremden hingezogen eröffnet
ihr seid und verspricht ihr einen
starken helfer holen
das geschöpf aus der kiste aus lehm
gefahren
ein künstlicher übermensch die neue
jüdische weise zum leben erwecken können
wir sind der hebräischen mythologie
überliefert ist wieder ein verweis auf
die filmgeschichte auf paul wegeners
stummfilmklassiker bohlen von 1920
[Musik]
monster ein zeitloses thema angesichts
der bedrohlich zunehmenden motorisierung
das hat den autor dietrich von bern
schweiz aktuell
als gutmütiger riesen schuftet der
kohlen für vier und hilft der bäuerin
aus den schulden
doch droht gefahr von fremden blick die
besten aus
[Musik]
monster gotthelf und wild west
der krude mix hat kolping für die
visuelle ausstrahlung der figuren und
szenen sorgten der zeichner kg und die
grafik diesem vorschlag ein team war hat
den golem ins emmental gebracht wo er
vom gutmütigen helfer zum rächer muti
und dafür verteufelt wird fordert
bereich holstein kombiniert und die
verachtung für ein happy end
so viel sei verraten ist kein platz in
dieser düsteren sagen
der golem unterliegt
[Musik]
angst und gier
intrigen und verrat sorgen dafür dass am
ende
[Musik]
böse 42